$5,000, don't kill yourself.
I first heard about Ramon
Abbas when he was arrested,
it was a pretty big
international news story.
He was arrested in Dubai,
and he was very quickly
extradited to the U.S.
Ramon Abbas, also known as Hushpuppi,
was responsible for a number of
business email compromise scams.
But what he was most known for was being
an Instagram influencer who built
a following of millions of people.
And it was always very mysterious
where his money actually came from.
According to the affidavit,
he was charged with $30
million worth of fraud.
Hushpuppi is the number
one Yahoo boy in Nigeria.
He's a role model to every
Yahoo boy in Nigeria.
There are ways to look at Hushpuppi,
not as some kind of hero,
but you can respect some
of the things that he did.
And the way that he thrived
in our current online
social media ecosystem.
One of the things people would ask me was
"Why did he post to Instagram?
He should have just kept a low profile."
My answer ultimately was,
why do you post on social media?
He was doing it for the
same reasons we all do it,
to get some response from people,
to feel his place in the
world grow and be respected.
G for Gucci.
When you look at the story from one layer
it's very simplistic.
But the deeper you get into it
the more you see the complexities around
how someone like Hushpuppi
exists in the modern world.
Ramon grew up in a neighborhood of Lagos
called Oworonshoki.
It's a bit of a hardscrabble neighborhood.
His father drove a taxi,
his mother sold bread and
other foods on the street.
By his own account he always looked
to the ritzier areas of
Lagos as a kind of dreamer.
And he wanted to have more for himself.
Today we have an exclusive inside look
at the internet scam that has
been sweeping this country
based out of Nigeria.
When the internet arrived
late '90s, early 2000s
in places like Ramon Abbas' neighborhood,
people would go down to the internet cafe.
And one of the things
that Nigerians discovered
when they logged on was that oftentimes
there was sort of a reputation
that proceeded them online.
They were already viewed
as being scammers,
because of the 419 scams
of the '80s and '90s,
which were either phone,
or fax, or letter scams.
This coincided as well with
more difficult economic
times within Nigeria,
fewer job prospects.
And so there was a community
who embraced that label
who decided, "Okay,
I will figure out how
to make money online.
I will figure out how to
take advantage of people."
And they're actually
incredibly innovative.
It started as it almost always does
with an email.
There was a community of young boys
who became known as the Yahoo boys,
based on the free email
accounts that were available,
for this type of scamming.
I spoke to a criminologist
in Nigeria, Adedeji,
he spent a lot of time with Yahoo boys.
And he actually lived for a
time among them to study them,
to understand their motivations,
to understand their techniques,
to see what became of them over time.
And he knew a lot of the same
people in Ramon's circle.
I have a very good relationship with them
because I saw them as human beings.
It was very popular in the slums.
Areas like Bariga,
Ajibola,
Ijora,
Mushin.
Because these are places where
you have a lot of young boys
who have very little life chances.
Hushpuppi, Ramon Abbas,
at that time he was one
of the very smart boys.
He went very far, he met a lot
of people who could help him
improve on the skills of cyber crime.
Knowing that the kind of cyber crime
we had in Nigeria in the early days
was close to the 419, the letter scam.
He moved from Nigeria to Malaysia.
And at the time in particular,
there was a sort of exodus of Yahoo boys
from Nigeria to Malaysia.
There are a variety of theories
about why they moved there.
The possibility that it
was a little more lax,
that the Nigerian government
was paying a little more
attention at that time.
Also because there was
more sophisticated internet
architecture there,
in terms of how you
could hide the location
that your requests were coming from.
He moved so that way he could
have access to all of the tools.
He wanted more information than
what every other person had,
and that was why he became what
most of them did not become.
It seems like he was connected to
several different flavors of scams.
One of which was business
email compromise,
which is the most lucrative
internet scam that exists.
Well today one of the
largest scams attacking users
is called the business email compromise.
The business email compromise
seems really, really sophisticated.
And during my career I've dealt
with hundreds of these incidents,
the bad guys are able to compromise
an email account of a business.
It could be a small business,
it could be a large business,
and it involves financial transactions.
You have a company,
and the company is going to
be targeted by the scammers.
And usually they'll research the company,
they're trying to find the right person.
And what they do is, a hacker
gets access to someone's email account.
So usually middle manager,
or someone in the accounting
department of a company.
Once they're in the email, they
don't actually do anything,
they just sit there and they wait.
And they watch the flow
of email in and out,
and when they see invoices
that's what they're looking for.
When an invoice comes in
they might spoof the email
of the sender of the invoice.
Mock up a fake invoice
that looks exactly like
the one that just came in,
and then send a follow up email saying,
"This was not the correct
bank account information,
this is the new bank."
If the financial department
is not looking carefully,
then they are prone to sending
the money right out the door.
That's essentially what BEC scams are.
Someone asked for this money
who's not the right person,
and you've sent them millions of dollars.
$20,000 here, okay?
$20,000.
I just spent $20,000.
Ramon had picked up the
handle Hushpuppi in,
I think 2012.
But it was really when he got to Malaysia
that he started posting
photos, mostly of himself.
It was a kid from Lagos on the rise,
here are the luxury brands
that I'm now consuming.
And he started mixing that
with a self-help mantras,
and a sort of prosperity gospel.
You know, the hustle.
His followers started
ticking up over time.
And then Hushpuppi began
a friendship with Mompha,
who's a very, very well
known influencer in Nigeria
and Mompha lived in Dubai.
That seems like the time
when he started to see
that there was another level of opulence,
there was another tier of
lifestyle that he could be living.
And so he packed up for
Malaysia, moved himself to Dubai.
When he moved to Dubai he
really entered this world of
truly high wealth individuals.
Which included obtaining
a penthouse apartment,
closets full of designer clothes.
Shelves of unopened sneakers,
sneakers that had only been made once,
sneakers that have been
made specifically for him.
And a basement parking
garage that was full of cars,
like Ferraris, Bentleys.
He's sometimes now
flying on private planes,
he's one of the guests of
honor at the Formula One race.
He's being invited to events in Dubai,
and so he's entered this upper crust
of some of the most wealthy
people in the world.
Everybody want to talk about Hushpuppi,
Hushpuppi do this, Hushpuppi do that.
Leave me alone, talk about yourself.
The difference between Hushpuppi
and the other Yahoo boys,
is the fact that he went international.
Then he went to the social media to
show off all of these things.
But as for recklessness,
there are all reckless,
even those who are not on
the international scenes
are also reckless.
That's where they live.
So at Hushpuppi's 37th birthday,
it was all kind of at that moment
it felt like it was really
coming together for a Hushpuppi.
And he posted about that,
he posted about how far he had come.
While that birthday
celebration was happening
the seeds of Hushpuppi's
downfall had already been sewn.
Well, he made the cardinal
sin in organized crime,
he flaunted his wealth.
He brought a lot of attention to himself,
he made himself appear
to be a national hero.
But when you were out there,
and you are flaunting
all of this information,
there's so much open source intelligence
that he was just providing about himself.
The FBI arrested a
Canadian money launderer,
and his name is Ghaleb Alaumary.
When they arrested Alaumary
he had a phone on him
in which there were
contacts for Hushpuppi.
And there were message
exchanges with Hushpuppi.
What they came to believe was that
Alaumary and Hushpuppi were part of
a loosely networked
group of people who were
committing BEC scams, and moving
the money around the world.
Oftentimes there would
be hackers who would
hack into the email accounts.
And the FBI later concluded these were
North Korean state sponsored hackers,
who had actually committed
billions of dollars
worth of crime around the
world over the past 10 years.
Alaumary would connect up with Hushpuppi,
ask him if he had any bank accounts.
And when a big BE score
was about to happen
Hushpuppi would provide a bank account
that could receive millions of dollars
that were about to be
transferred out of a company.
The crimes that they were accused of
included the large-scale
hacking of a bank in Malta
for $13 million.
A BEC scam on an American law firm
for just under a million dollars.
The biggest one was an attempted BEC scam
on two U.K. companies,
both of which were for around
a hundred million dollars.
And one of which was
an English premier league football team.
In early June, June 8th,
Hushpuppi was asleep upstairs
on the second floor of his apartment.
There was a bang on the door,
and then suddenly the apartment
was full of people with guns.
At first he thought they were
victims of an armed robbery,
but then it quickly turned out
it was the Dubai SWAT team.
And they'd come in fully kitted up,
and they were ready for war.
He was whisked onto a
plane within, I think,
24 to 48 hours and sent to the U.S.
If you are to classify Hushpuppi,
how would you classify him?
Busted.
I give a lot of credit to the FBI agents
who arrested Hushpuppi.
But we are not going to arrest
our way out of this problem.
We took one bad guy off the streets,
but how many more of them are out there?
I think even though we believe Mr Abbas
is a major player in this,
he's only a bit player in
the entire infrastructure
of the complete organization.
There are just so many actors,
and so many elements in these schemes,
including organized crime
in places like Russia,
and places like Brazil.
That it's really, really
hard to make a dent I think
in the power of the BEC scam.
To me one of the tragedies
of this whole situation
is that because of the reputation
of scamming in Nigeria,
law enforcement there,
particularly with the
Special Anti-Robbery Squad,
they ended up using
scammers and Yahoo boys
as just a pretext.
All of a sudden down the street
arresting every young guy
for being involved in cyber
crime without any evidence.
They just pack a group of young boys,
they force them to say a
lot of things and them poom.
It became one of the reasons why we had
what we had in Nigeria last year.
For weeks now there
have been demonstrations
against police brutality
across Africa's most populous country.
Protestors accused the now disbanded
Special Anti-Robbery
Squad, or SARS, of torture.
They've been notorious for
extrajudicial killings, and
harassment, especially of young Nigerians.
End SARS in Nigeria was
a big deal last year,
a lot of lives were lost.
And up to this moment
we are still trying to
pacify young people.
Cyber crime is not a problem of Nigeria
or for Nigeria,
it's a problem from
every part of the world.
We need a global cyber crime law,
if we have a law,
and we also have global
law enforcement agencies,
then we are moving towards
managing cyber crime.